today's conversation
builds on the foundation of multi-armed
bandits
bandit problems represent an essential
conflict that we have in human nature
choosing actions which yield immediate
benefit
now versus choosing actions which might
yield benefit
somewhat later on jam tomorrow multi-arm
bandits are best explained through this
analogy
a gambler at a row of slot machines
needs to decide which machine to play
how many times to play and which
machines to play on
when played each machine will give a
reward which is specific
to a distribution from that machine the
objective is to maximize a reward earned
through a sequence of lever pools
dr walter kulin gives us his take
on multi-arm bandits so it's in some
sense an abstraction
but so what are the ingredients so you
have these things
called arms an interface if you want an
arm is something you can you can pull it
it's what it's called
and what does is a sample is generated
from some
unknown distribution that is behind this
arm
so in a multi-arm bandit you have a
collection of arms
and you can ask for samples
interactively so you ask for a sample
you see what
what you got and you go to another arm
ask for a sample
and you keep on going like this and i
guess one
one popular application would be a
clinical trials
so then you think of each treatment that
you're testing
as one of these bandit arms and you
think of
pulling such an arm as getting another
patient and applying this treatment to
this patient
and and observing the effect if the
effect is quite fast
then you can really use the feedback
from this
single patient in to update your
knowledge about the treatments
so maybe for the next patient you would
like if the patient worked
if the treatment worked well on the next
patient you might want to give it again
and if it didn't work so well you may
want to weight it down
okay that's what a bandit is so it's
basically several
unknown probability distributions
multi-arm bandits are theoretically a
really interesting problem and the
reason for that is schematically
they represent many other more
sophisticated problems
the scientific answer is these problems
are
baby versions of the problem that we
really would like to solve
where they are distilled to a level
where
all the interesting features are still
there
so what is pure exploration well pure
exploration
means not exploiting anything an example
of this is
alphago which does pure exploration
through simulation and self-play
but it turns out you can do pure
exploration in the real world
for example clinical trials so the
process is pure exploration
when the objective is not to maximize
the reward itself
but to come up with a recommendation to
maximize the reward so in these decision
theoretical frameworks there's always
an exploration versus exploitation
trade-off
an example of an approach to ameliorate
this is the epsilon greedy algorithm
so most of the time ninety percent of
the time
select the lever that you know is the
best one but ten percent of the time
have a uniform random sample choose a
lever
randomly and just see what happens so
classically this is this exploration
exploitation trade-off and you have a
framework
that you call pure exploration now as i
understand it you can still use it's not
just it's not as simple as saying let's
just do exploration
so what do you understand under pure
exploration and how does that play in
how can you
do exploitation using pure exploration
the other end of the spectrum is the
trial that you're running
because you want to mass produce one of
your drugs
okay so you're doing the trial to figure
out which of these drugs
you're going to roll out in the world
so you're not really caring about curing
the patients
what's important is that you want to
find out which of these drugs works best
because that's for example a covet
vaccine this is super
current yes maybe something like that
yeah so this is the regime in which the
kofi
trials are being done is it fair to say
that the pure exploration setting
is some sort of a setting where the
reward
is a sort of information gain
that's exactly right so we'll be talking
about these two settings a lot
router gives another example of pure
exploration in the context of a board
game
you want to have the best possible
recommendation for the move to take
and after all that process is finished
you send the move over to the real board
and one move is made but that one you
can never retract
you made it it's committed so all that
process was used to make that move
really good
so this is a pure exploration welter
goes on to discuss
generalized bandits and even bandits
which may become
intractable i think the adversarial one
is really in a category on its own
so in the stochastic bandit model the
thing to learn
exists it is the full parametrization of
the true model
whereas in an adversarial setting all
the structure evaporates
and the amount of exploration you need
even for reward maximization
is just higher because you have to catch
the opponent
changing the patterns in some sense it's
funny but i always
so exploration is in that sense you use
it as a threat
i might look everywhere right right so
don't try to hide
a reward that i'm not seeing we talk
about the wide
applicability of multi-armed banded
analysis to such things
relevant today like covet vaccine
development and trials
or solving different social policy
problems
did i prescribe the right one it's not
important that i know which one
is the right one at the end i just have
to have handed it out
a lot there's a new class of problem
here the ethical
multi-armed bandit yeah so i think
regulatory
agencies have something to say about
these things and it can even range
much farther than that problems of
agents running in your home
or even more general settings to spin
this a little bit further
it seems that the framework is
applicable
to so much more i'm thinking of any
agent being deployed anywhere
as something like this for example yeah
let's go back to
your classic reinforcement learning
problem you have a robot
you deploy it in a house and the first
thing
it could do is simply to go and explore
right such that it can then after that
do
a certain task or any task as good as
possible
we explore what wildtrue calls a
renaissance
and multi-armed bandit analysis lower
bounds
that have become so tight that they
actually enable
the calculation of optimal algorithms
that are not only optimal asymptotically
but optimal and practical scenarios with
finite samples
that could be extremely useful for
people designing
clinical trials they could definitely
understand something like look the
recommendation is that you do
linear proportioning or logarithmic or
whatever
do we have that kind of catalog today of
heuristics for different scenarios
i i like this question i think here the
answer my feeling is the answer is yes
so i i think of this as the sort of the
renaissance
in pure exploration it says you can get
extremely close to optimality
on large samples so this is what this
asymptotic optimality the excitement
that it gave
like we can have the constant vector
equal to one on top of the lower bound
in our algorithms we can
really squeeze everything out so for
best arm the asymptotics kick in quite
early
so for practical sample sizes these
algorithms are are just
the best we have yet the story is mixed
and there seems to be some high
sensitivity of the algorithm to those
lower bounds
small changes in the bounds actually can
result in
fundamentally different algorithms how
much you think these
refinements those bounds would
qualitatively change
the algorithms that are optimal yeah so
i think unfortunately the algorithms are
very different so the the examples in
which
the non confidence terms are dominant
have different lower bounds with that
term being the dominant one and then the
algorithms that match those
look very different again so if you want
to quantify this
in regret maximization you play some
optimal arms
logarithmically often this is in the
stochastic setting but i think this is
what we're currently talking about
in the pure exploration you are handing
out suboptimal
drugs linearly often so a fixed fraction
of your trial
is spent on handing out all the bad
drugs just to make sure
that they really are worse so between
logarithmic and linear
is an is an enormous distinction yeah
right if you run either algorithm in the
for the one task in the other one it's
really not going to do
very well i think so the problem is
you're facing this impossibility
that an algorithm that's good for one is
not going to be
good for the other this makes it
difficult to offer general heuristics or
guidelines for a practitioner who may
not be able to conduct a thorough
analysis of their particular problem
but here there seems to be hope the
possibility of creating what wilder
calls
a pure exploration compiler
okay so this is my dream i've been
writing research proposals about this i
know it's impossible and it's crazy
but still i think it's a very nice goal
so i call it the pure exploration
compiler
so you can look at that lower bound fill
in the details of your problem
crank the technology and outcomes and
almost
it's an algorithm what would that look
like if there were a contract or a
domain specific language or
some kind of concise description
what would the minimal contract be
we had a bit of fun too learning about a
particularly fearsome multi-armed bandit
that tim
brought with them to graduate school for
tim who at some point came in with
a truck and and offloaded the largest
monster desktop
i ever saw with lights and everything
and then he decided to overclock it to
about twice
the clock frequency and then at some
point there were these blue screens now
and then
that were interrupting all the
experiments going on
we also had a bit of light-hearted
banter at the end of the show about
quantum
yeah yeah we should like do street talk
quantum something i hear companies
getting
funding for things that have nothing to
do with what the company does
but they like frame their work in a way
is oh yeah we got some covet funding
it's like you do you're like you do
nothing no
quantum quantum bottled water yeah right
it's all a matter of framing to get
these government
money things blockchain coffee
anyway we've really delved into the
theoretical side of machine learning in
today's episode
i've not really seen this side of
machine learning in a long time it
brings me back to my
phd in computer science days do you like
this kind of content
was it heavy going did we do a good
enough job of explaining it
let us know in the comments i'm super
excited about some of the episodes we
have
in the pipeline ready to go we have got
some
absolutely incredible episodes coming up
so yeah i'm excited about
it and of course we'll be releasing
those over over the christmas period so
i hope you're looking forward to it as
well remember to like
comment and subscribe and we'll see you
back
very soon enjoy the episode and thanks
for joining
us here we are and welcome back to the
machine learning street talk youtube
channel
and podcast with my two compadres mit
phd
keith duggar and yannick lightspeed
kiltchef now today we have an incredibly
special guest
dr walter kulin i did my phd with
voucher actually and what i remember
most fondly about the welter is the
distinctive way in which he used to
answer his phone
he used to say this is walter and i
could
still remember that really clearly 10
years old but walter was super deep into
decision theoretic online learning
and in particular prediction with expert
advice at the time which is what i was
doing as well on my phd
welcher is definitely the smartest
person i've ever met in real life
one thing i know for sure if it wasn't
for walter i wouldn't have a phd now
he spent countless hours explaining
things to me and just giving me starting
points and research ideas and i'm
forever in his depth for that welter is
a computer scientist and senior
researcher in the machine learning group
at cwi
in amsterdam which is ironically right
next to we just interviewed max welling
a couple of hours ago so
in the same city welter specializes in
machine learning theory
game theory information theory
statistics
and optimization walt is currently
interested in pure exploration
in multi-armed bandit models games
research and accelerated learning in
sequential decision problems
his research has been cited around a
thousand times
he's been published in eurips which is
the number one machine learning
conference literally 14 times
as well as lots of other exciting
publications so it's pretty impressive
today we're going to talk about two of
the most studied settings in control and
decision theory and learning in unknown
environments
which are the multi-armed bandit problem
and the reinforcement learning approach
so there's a couple of key questions
here which is when can an agent
stop learning and start exploiting using
the knowledge that it's obtained
and which strategy leads to the minimal
learning time
anyway walter it's an absolute pleasure
to have you on the show and welcome
thank you very much tim that was very
generous it was a it was a pleasure to
be with you
when you were doing your phd what was he
like yeah
okay maybe one little anecdote so
everybody at our university had a very
nice little what are these things called
a thin client except for tim who at some
point came in with
a truck and offloaded the largest
monster desktop
i ever saw with lights and everything
and then he decided to overclock it to
about twice
the clock frequency and then at some
point there were these blue screens now
and then
that were interrupting all the
experiments going on
so i think there was a trade-off to be
found i know that
ironically you are utilizing my hardware
with your matlab experiments much more
so
than quake 3 was so gaming rigs have
pros and cons for research
that's the point yeah i've been wanting
to install
doom on our 8 gpu machines for a while
so accurate let me jump into this bandit
thing like eight i've been at
i've been to two tuner rips now a few
times and
other conferences and there's always new
research and there's transformers and
then there's
gans and there's all the fancy stuff
there's always this corner
this and in the corner there are
the bandits and it's it never dies like
you think that at some point it's okay
which panda to
pull like number three cool like there
is a multi-arm banded problem
and i guess there are like some basic
algorithms ucb
and things like this what's the
continuous
deal about multi-armed bandits why do
they persist
and why do they let's say what's
why does the field keep going with what
seems to be a very
basic problem yeah excellent question
so the way i think of it is there are
two answers
so let me first give the the small
answer which is
some problems are multi-arm banded
problems and i think one of the
one of the things that we often see as
motivation in paper is like
ad placement or clinical trials
so these fit exactly in the multi-arm
banded protocol
and they have like large firms behind
them
so there is like a financial interest in
solving these problems but i think from
a more like the scientific answer is
these problems are baby versions
of the problem that we really would like
to solve
where they are distilled to a level
where
all the interesting features are still
there
so it's simplified but not too much
and i think that niche is where the
multi-are banded
that corner that you're talking about
the maybe the theory
crowd at nurips but you see the same
thing at
for example colt which is a even more
theoretical conference
there is also uh like the multi-armed
engine contingent
so this problem if you solve
multi-arm-banded
problems you get the foundation for
solving these
more complicated problems for example in
like optimization derivative-free
optimization
reinforcement learning solving like two
player games
these are all built with little banded
sub problems inside
and there is not one banded problem
for some problems we have pretty good
algorithms
like you mentioned ucb which is the
textbook algorithm for a regret
minimization
but for other problems we we're still
actually figuring out
what is the right answer even in this
very simple bandit setting
and and this is where the pure
exploration sort of
also has its starting point so there are
lots of pure exploration problems in
multi-arm bandits for which we don't
quite know
how to even design algorithms could we
talk about the hierarchy here of the
different approaches so when we met
we were doing online learning and
there seems to be a taxonomy of decision
theoretical
approaches for doing this i think we
were working in what's called the full
information domain
where your actions don't really affect
anything you observe everything and the
future doesn't care
and you don't really have to make many
assumptions in that so we were doing
prediction with expert advice
and then there's this middle tier which
is bandits where your action
affects the observation and it's quite
simple in a way
so your actions affect what you see but
not what happens after and then what
everyone's talking about now is
reinforcement learning
which is where your action affects the
future state so there's a lot of
planning and thinking ahead that needs
to happen so
we're kind of in in the middle of those
two things
yeah that's exactly right i just want to
point out something
am i correct by way of analogy so
the multi-armed bandit is the decision
theory as the
urn is the probability theory right
like it's the simplest problem the urn
filled with different colored balls and
we can imagine
sampling with replacement without
replacement multiple urns that are
adversarial etcetera it's the simplest
context
that as you said allows you to explore
all the salient features
of decision theory is that true
yeah so maybe we should explain what a
multi-our bandit is
so it's in some sense an abstraction but
so what are the ingredients so you have
these things
called arms an interface if you want an
arm is something you can you can pull it
it's what it's called
and what it does is a sample is
generated from some
unknown distribution that is behind this
arm
so in a multi-arm bandit you have a
collection of arms
and you can ask for samples
interactively so you ask for a sample
you see what
what you got and you go to another arm
ask for a sample
and you keep on going like this and i
guess one
one popular application would be a
clinical trials
so then you think of each treatment that
you're testing
as one of these banded arms and you
think of
pulling such an arm as getting another
patient and applying this treatment to
this patient and
observing the effect if the effect is
quite fast
then you can really use the feedback
from this
single patient in to update your
knowledge about the treatments
so maybe for the next patient you would
like if the patient worked if the
treatment worked well
on the next patient you might want to
give it again
and if it didn't work so well you may
want to weight it down
okay that's what a bandit is so it's
basically several
unknown probability distributions
in some of your talks you talked about
the generalizations of this right or as
you said there are many classes of
of bandits you can generalize on the
distribution of the reward on
whether they're adversarial or not et
cetera i'm curious about one thing that
i think i missed
in some of those generalizations what's
the generalization called where you
instead of pulling one arm and then
updating
in parallel you pull multiple arms with
a weight so for example like a portfolio
distribution i can distribute my pulls
fractionally
across all the arms pull once and then
update does that generalization get
studied much
like in the clinical trial example if
i've got a thousand patients yes
i allocate 10 to this treatment 50 to
that and do so in a way that's
intelligent is that studied
i think it's definitely a practical
setting especially if the treatment
takes some time
so you don't want to wait for the
outcome but you want to launch
a collection of experiments with certain
proportions
and then after that batch you may want
to change the proportions and maybe do
another batch
does that have a name the fractional
poll or
you can also think of it as you're
committing yourself to not
have too many decision points you could
think of all these
treatments as happening sequentially in
time you just decide that you only look
after a thousand after two thousand you
change your
allocation so in that sense it's like a
very restrained interaction compared to
the one where you look after every
treatment but you may be forced to do
this by the fact that you get your
feedback with such a delay or what i was
thinking about too is stock trading if i
have
2 000 stocks in which i can invest i
don't do it by
putting my entire portfolio in one and
then waiting till tomorrow and seeing
what happens
instead i do a distribution across all
the stocks
trade for a day or however long doesn't
matter
and then i react to it so i'm just
wondering how widely it's studied and
what that class of multi-armed bandits
is properly called i see but i think
we may need to make a distinction here
because in the portfolio setting
i think you are in the full information
setting
and the fact that you put an allocation
over these stocks it really means you
are splitting your
your capital and investing portions in
each
but if you have several unknown
distributions
it doesn't really make sense to ask for
half a sample from one of them
outside of a pure learning context or
pure exploration it does
because if i'm trying to so first of all
in the stocks there's is a lot of
unknown you don't know what the
distribution of returns are going to be
for today
but more importantly i am trying to
learn but i'm also
trying to optimize my portfolio and so
if i'm doing both simultaneously that's
where the fractional
spread i think comes into play your i
think
what the disconnect is maybe
if you assume that you are not such a
big player
you will still know what the
distribution is tomorrow even if you
didn't invest
into a particular stock right like i can
still look up the price of apple
tomorrow even if i do or don't invest i
i see the distribution is unknown but
the kind of band
i think when you pull a banded arm you
do get
some sort of a reward maybe either the
treatment works or it doesn't
but also you get information what what
what the distribution behind it is maybe
that's the disconnect that
actually be my sort of question leading
up
in that often in these band-aid problems
you have this
you're tasked with doing something like
maximizing a reward maximizing the
number of patients that are healed and
so on
but you have these unknown distributions
i have 10 treatments
and i have to try them a certain amount
of time before they
before i know how well they work right
so classically this is this exploration
exploitation trade-off and you have a
framework
that you call pure exploration now as i
understand it you can still
use it's not just it's not as simple as
saying
let's just do exploration so what do you
understand
under pure exploration and how does that
play in how can you
do exploitation using pure exploration
all right so i think the i think
maybe let's start with an example of the
two so again let's suppose you are
running a clinical trial
so you're working in this bandit
interaction model where you have a
patient and you can prescribe a
treatment
and you see the result and then you go
move on to the next patient
right now in this interaction you can
still have
several different goals and these
correspond to
whether you're doing pure exploration or
exploitation
exploration exploitation so the version
where you
want to cure the people that are
in your sample so you want to actually
cure the
patients that you are treating right now
so what you want to do there is you want
to learn about the treatments
enough so that you can prescribe most of
the time
the one that works best because that's
helping the patients
so that's something you would do for a
rare disease for example there aren't
that many patients
but you would like to cure the ones that
come to your clinic
the other end of the spectrum is the the
trial that you're running because you
want to mass produce
one of your drugs okay so you're doing
the trial to figure out
which of these drugs you're going to
roll out
in the world so you're not really caring
about
curing the patients what's important is
that you want to find out which of these
drugs works best
because that for example a copic vaccine
this is super
current yes maybe something like that
yeah so this is the regime in which the
kofi
trials are being done you you really
it's not the point
to cure the patients that get like the
000 people that get that depends on
which trial you're in but
the people that get a test that gets
vaccine right now
it's not the point to cure them or
immunize them
it's the point is to know which of these
vaccines
is the best one because that's the one
that needs to be scaled out
to billions and that's just too
expensive to do that for all of them
so you want to it turns out and this is
what gets me interested
is that if you want to find out which of
them works best
your scheme for which treatment to
assign
to the patients that are in your trial
is
quite different between the pure
exploration where you want to know
which drug is the best and the
let's say the decision theoretic version
or the exploitation exploration
in interleaving where you're trying to
actually prescribe
most of the time the best drug
so that's a behavioral
task did i prescribe the right one it's
not important that i know which one
is the right one at the end i just have
to have handed it out
a lot there's a new class of problem
here the ethical
multi-armed bandit because now we have
to consider ethics too
yeah so i think regulatory agencies have
something to say about these things
and i think at least the traditional
viewpoint is that you're not allowed to
do
the the one where you run the trial
adaptively
so the the purpose of your trial is to
establish that the drug works
[Music]
or to figure out between several doses
which is the one
that works best and then after that sort
of accredited
you can sell it but it's
it's very different to treat the
patients in the trial
so is it fair to say is it fair to say
that the pure exploration setting
is some sort of a setting where the
reward
is a sort of information gain
like you you want to perform
the experiment that maximally that gains
you maximal information about
all of the distributions there are is
that's exactly right that's exactly
right
and so it turns out that if you want to
so we'll be talking about these two
settings a lot so
let's think about them as reward
maximization
versus pure exploration so in reward
once you have a good idea about which
drug is
reasonably good so you think this is the
best but you're actually quite uncertain
you start handing it out almost all the
time
and once in a while you throw in one of
the drugs that are currently looking
worse
to make sure that your picture of them
is not perturbed by noise
so you are handing them out but slower
and slower
and you're most of the time handing out
the one you think is best
whereas in in pure exploration it's not
important for you
to to get lots of cures
you want lots of information and it
turns out for this it is
necessary to hand out much more often
drugs
that you currently think are not the
best
but you want to be very sure that they
are worse than your current
best-looking candidate and to be sure
about that you need to reduce the
uncertainty
on how good they are and for this you
need to hand them out
much more often so if you want to
quantify this
in regret maximization you place some
optimal arms
logarithmically often this is in the
stochastic setting but i think this is
what we're currently talking about
in the pure exploration you are handing
out suboptimal
drugs linearly often so a fraction a
fixed fraction of your time of your
trial is
spent on handing out all the bad drugs
just to make sure
that they really are worse so between
logarithmic and linear
is an is an enormous distinction yeah
right if you run either algorithm in the
for the one task in the other one it's
really not going to do very well
it sounds so that a point that yannick
just made i think if
if i heard them correctly is that these
two extremes
in a sense are just zero and one weights
of different objective functions so is
there a sort of generalized
objective function that can span these
extremes between
is it just a difference in objective
function really
yeah so it's definitely a difference but
i so i think
i have fakely seen some work where
people are trying to
interpolate but i think so the problem
is you have to
it's you're facing this impossibility
that an algorithm that's good for one is
not going to be good for the other
so once you make an intermediate
objective
there's going to be a huge struggle
between these two
and so i think the algorithms that are
what you
what would be the holy grail is if you
could make some algorithm that just is
dominant in all these tasks right and
such an interpolation
would maybe allow you to discover it but
i think instead what you get is you get
something that works really well for the
interpolation
but it is useless at the end points
again
so these objectives are actually very
different
could we describe what a strategy looks
like because i was reading some of the
information you sent over and
typically an algorithm has a sampling
rule a stopping rule and a decision rule
and that makes up a strategy
and there's also some operating
characteristics so there's a fixed
confidence regime
and there's a fixed budget regime which
is that you say okay i'm only going to
have
a certain number of draws and then i
have to stop so
presumably that determines the type of
algorithm that might be designed
that's right so the maybe we should talk
very briefly about these how do you
measure success
of your algorithm so this is where this
fixed confidence fixed budget
and maybe simple regret objectives come
in
i like most fixed confidence
so let's talk about that afterwards but
maybe i should say what these other two
are
so fixed budget means you commit up
front to a number of
samples and you are going to try
to optimize the probability that you
identify at the end the the best arm
so you're taking a fixed number of
samples you adaptively allocate them
to the arms that you have and at the
very end you output
a recommendation for the best arm based
on what you saw
so you say treatment 6 is the best
that's what i think
and then in the design of your algorithm
you try to make it such that this
recommendation is correct with very high
probability
so that's that's one setup where you fix
the sample size
and you optimize the probability of
getting the right answer
so that fits with clinical trials quite
well right yes
right so the other so fixed confidence
is actually the
the flip of this where you say i will
tolerate
a certain error probability maybe five
percent
so that i will make as a constraint on
my algorithm it's allowed to be wrong
five percent of the time and given that
constraint i would like to optimize
the number of samples that it takes so
few fewer samples is better
and this allows you to stop at some
earlier point so the algorithm can
decide itself when it has seen enough
samples to make a recommendation
and for example this allows you that to
stop so for example if you see that one
of your treatments is clearly much
better than the rest
you don't have to go on until some
prefix sample size you can just
stop and output the answer
so yeah you have a bit more freedom here
it's the stopping is under the control
of the algorithm too
so that's analogous to monte carlo
versus las vegas
algorithms monte carlo being the fixed
budget i'm going to run for a certain
amount of time
and then get the answer whereas las
vegas i get the answer but i don't know
how long it's going to take
yeah so i'm not familiar with those two
but that sounds exactly right
so when you when we connect this to
let's say
reinforcement learning with it which is
a thing that
maybe nowadays people are more familiar
with
first of all just the observation that a
lot of rl algorithms
use something called epsilon greedy
exploration
that sounds a lot like the kind of
linear
linearly i'm going to do something that
i think is dumb
but um i just gonna throw it in there so
i just i don't know i i thought that
wasn't that was an interesting
connection but
where do you see where do you see the
the connection between
current reinforcement learning as we
you know see it in let's say deep
reinforcement learning and so on
and your type of research
all right maybe i should give an example
because there is a motivating
example that got me thinking about all
of this in which all these differences
come out i think quite clearly
and this is suppose you are solving a
game
so we've all heard about alphago so
let's take that as an example so there
is a real
go board with some opponent on the other
side
and it's your turn to make a move okay
and so what you so you're building an
algorithm
to fit to find that move for you
so what are you going to do so you're
going to run some sort of a
simulation but it's all virtual it
doesn't have anything to do with the
real board
in which you start from the board where
you are and you will allow
your learning or your search algorithm
to make moves
so it will make a move for you for the
opponent for you for your opponent and
it will at some point maybe
terminate the game and look at the score
right so
your job is to make an learning
algorithm
for figuring out a good move
right and then so maybe without going
into too much detail but
the search tree for go is just massive
there's no way to
to just process everything brute force
and so the approximation that is very
successful
is actually based internally on sampling
so it's running randomized strategies
for both players
that are also designed by the learning
algorithm but this
makes it a bandit style problem
internally
so what internally is happening is the
learning algorithm is deciding
where in the tree to look a little bit
more to gain some information
and so you can ask like what should a
learning algorithm
be doing and the traditional
algorithms so if you think about regret
or if you think about reward
maximization
then what your algorithm is doing in
this
search process is it's spending effort
at parts of the search tree where
you are winning and
are you describing the monte carlo tree
search that
is actually used by deep mind
yes yeah so this i think monte carlo
research is a
very cool and powerful but also a bit
complicated
cloud of ideas but if you simplify it
down it's really thinking like where
should i spend my computational budget
to learn more about the best move in
this starting board
could you sketch out what's going on
there without the go because it's it's a
convolutional neural network
it's a policy a deep learning policy
which
tells you which action to take next and
then they have this monte carlo research
on the top
so it's a kind of weird mix of learning
and searching all in one so
roughly what happens when the next move
is selected
so one way to think of it but i'm not
really an expert
in this but i still i think it's just
nice
so one way in which you could play go
is to have what's called an evaluation
function
so you make some black books in which
you input a board configuration and it
tells you how good this
configuration is for you and then if you
want to play go
you look at your board you look at the
possible moves for you
you evaluate them and you go with the
highest
and it turns out that making such an
evaluation function is just
extremely difficult and so what the
monte carlo tree search
does is instead of looking at one-step
expansions
of your current state it's trying to go
deeper
but you have the explosion of states
again
so it's not uniformly expanding
everywhere
but it's trying to go deeper in the
places that matter
right until some point where maybe still
you invoke some evaluation function
but that function is now much closer to
the end of the game
so it's hopefully more precise and
easier to learn
and then this monte carlo tree search
process tries to do strategic reasoning
like really min max min max except of
course the branching factor is too high
so
there are some compromises are made but
it's in a sense it's a
to lift a reasonable evaluation function
to a very good evaluation function by
spending time
in the play phase instead of spending
time learning more
then one of the reasons you might want
to do it is because the expressive power
of your black box is not high enough
to express all that if you evaluate
after one step
so that function is maybe very
complicated
whereas if you go deeper down and lift
the expressive power with
with some min max search at least some
layers of it
you might have a more better evaluation
function in the end
is there a relation here to markets for
example
it's an interesting setting where when
you interact with the system or the
environment
it changes it's a similar thing in go
so it's not necessarily possible in one
step
to predict realistically
what might happen in in the future it i
guess what i'm saying is there's a
dichotomy between
learning and search is search always
necessary
yeah so i think the answer to the last
part is no
if your evaluation function would be
perfect you don't need any search but
how to get such an evaluation function
you may not need an evaluation function
if you can do
search all the way till the end so that
works for small games but it's
very you know very quickly this becomes
intractable
the thing about games let's see to go
towards your markets question
i think the nice thing about games is
that you can in principle
you can see the entire state space so at
least
you know what the possibilities are
whereas if you the the more real life
you try to make it
the less practical that even that
becomes
so maybe i should try to go one one
level up the stack because we were
talking about when do i want to do
reward maximization versus pure
exploration
so i think the the setting where you are
you are governing computational
attention
for planning purposes in this game
this is clearly a pure exploration
setting
it doesn't matter if you think about
games in which you lose or games about
in which you win
right you want to have the best possible
recommendation for the move to take
and after all that process is finished
you send the move over to the real board
and one move is made but that one you
can never retract
you made it it's it's committed so all
that process was used to make that move
really good
so this is a pure exploration question
and i think i got interested in this
because the methods that are used
for solving that type of question are
actually built
on top of reward
smaller parts so i was
curious whether that's a mismatch and
whether that something can be improved
so the other side is suppose your
algorithm is
actually playing the game so it can't
the only thing it can do is make a move
and then it's fed a new board and it
makes a move again and then at some
point it hears
sorry you lost back to the start right
and so there you suddenly reward is
i reached the winning state and i got
some reward
right so if you want to make an
algorithm for that setting
then it suddenly matters a lot what sort
of games because those are your reward
signal
it's not this planning that's happening
imaginarily
i'm curious we talked a lot about games
and and games are fun but the problems
we really want to solve
are in real life and as you just alluded
to you very quickly even at games can
get out of context
so for example you're playing texas hold
them and now you have
imperfect information again
combinatorial explosion
variable vet bet size et cetera and i
was really intrigued by something you
said earlier about
when you look at say a pure exploration
context you want to distribute linearly
versus logarithmically what would be
i'm wondering is there a catalog of if
you're in this decision criteria
like according to the best multi-armed
banded analysis that we have
here's a heuristic you should be
following because it occurs to me that
could be extremely useful
for people designing like clinical
trials they may not understand the
theory and the math behind
the multi-arm abandoned analysis but
they could definitely understand
something like look the the
recommendation is that you do
linear proportioning or logarithmic or
whatever do we have that kind of catalog
today
of heuristics for different scenarios i
i like this question
maybe first i put on my my
theoretician's head and say
nothing not a heuristic maybe but do we
have a real guideline
but it might be complicated and i think
here the answer
my feeling is the answer is yes so i i
think of this as the
sort of the renaissance in uh
pure exploration because pure
exploration has been around
there are some traces like all the way
back to maybe even the
you know 30s 70s 80s but then in the
early 2000s
paper started appearing with bounce
being proven for algorithms
but these were always in the worst case
flavor
and then in 2016 a completely new style
of algorithm design
was proposed this is a very nice paper
by garyv kaufman
and so the way this works is they say
let's see if we can make very good lower
bounds
for this problem so the lower bound
would say
if your algorithm is doing a good job so
its recommendations are trustworthy
it makes only a small proportion of
errors
then it needs to take at least a certain
number of samples
so that's in principle bad news because
it said i can't beat
this information theoretic limit but
their insight was
that these lower bounds you can make
them so sharp
that they actually also inform you
about how an algorithm would look that
matches that
so algorithms typically give upper
bounds lower bound arguments give lower
bounds and there is no real
reason that these should be connected
but what they
learn what they taught us is that a
specific style of lower bounds is so
good
that you can actually base algorithms on
top of them
so now this lower bound is depends on
the
specific problem that you have so there
is one lower bound for
like best arm identification which is
the sort of vanilla banded problem
there is another lower bound for game
style problems
there might be another lower bound for
path planning style problems
maybe nash equilibrium style problems
some robustness
problems with clinical trials maybe all
of these have a different
lower bound but the overall structure is
sort of generic so you can look at that
lower bound
fill in the details of your problem
crank the technology
and outcomes and almost it's an
algorithm almost
you know it's the main ingredient of an
algorithm comes out
and so what this says is how many
samples
should uh be allocated to each of these
arms if i know
the problem that i'm in
under this correctness constraint that
even if you're not in that problem you
should still give the right answer
but so this this can then be leveraged
so you don't know the specific bandit
that you're in that's actually your
learning problem
but you can estimate the bandit i use
this lower bound technique
to get the corresponding optimal
sampling allocation
and try to get that sampling allocation
implemented as you're going forward
so what effort is there being made to
turn this into an app
like that an experimenter can just put
in their criteria in a way that's very
understandable
and boom here's the sample alex yes okay
so this is my dream
i've been writing research proposals
about this i know it's impossible and
it's crazy
but still i think it's a very nice goal
so i call it the pure exploration
compiler
the compiler and the idea would be so
the state of research right now is that
people think of another interesting
problem
and start crunching out this lower bound
trying to uh get some maybe closed form
insights or otherwise make computational
solvers
for that lower bound problem and then
they have another paper where they say i
now
solved pure exploration into this and
that
so this could be like structural
assumptions prior knowledge about your
bandit
because these lower bounds take that
into account or it could be a
complicated
output so let's give me a path instead
of an arm or give me
all sorts of game related things yeah i
like these games i come back to them a
lot
but ideally what you would you should
you would like to go level up even more
and say can i make a language
in which i can describe these the the
task
and maybe the prior assumptions that i'm
willing to make
of structural knowledge about my bandit
can i describe these and then feed that
thing
into an algorithm that then outputs
the optimal sampling strategy even
because it can
so what would that look like if there
were a contract or a domain specific
language or
some kind of concise description
what would the minimal contract b
so i guess what it it needs to support
there i think there are really two sides
to this so on the one side you want to
say what do i
what am i willing to assume about my
bandit problem
and one of the ingredients is people
have often make
parametric assumptions about the arms so
it's bernoulli or gaussian or
maybe it's a bounded on zero one but
otherwise
non-parametric there are standard
assumptions that people are willing to
make
so it should be able to express those
and one of the ways to generalize over
these parametric families
is to specify the divergence function
so there is something called the
coolback lipid divergence
it's defined between it's sort of
information distance between
these distributions and these lower
bounds only use that
about your pro about your arms so if you
can
implement this distribution that could
be a computational
oracle that you can feed into this
compiler
it could also be expressed in terms of
some basis functions
logarithms exponentials maybe a few
other
maybe it's all it's always convex so
maybe you want to
write it in such a way that is obvious
so there is this thing called
disciplined convex programming
which allows you to do that but i'm
thinking of the domain knowledge maybe
have to has to go
in that shape and then there is the
how do i express when my answer is
correct
for example i want to have sort of a
language in which you can express
best arm because that's the basic
problem that has to be in there
these game tree problems so where i can
say
there is a deep min max but i only care
about the first move all the things you
might think of
are for example i give you some some
prototypes
so some points in some space
and i would like you to tell me so these
are maybe bandits
and i'd like you to tell me that whether
the so the bandit that you're in
is maybe closest to one of them tell me
which one
so do i look like this one that one or
that one maybe not precisely but which
one is closest
so that's also i think a natural problem
that you'd like to be
expressible in the language in which you
write your query
but so i think a good starting point
would be
to allow linear functions of the vector
of the means
so typically to describe a bandit if
it's in a parametric family
you just enumerate the means of all the
arms if it's parametrized one to one
then that
specifies everything and then what it
means let's say for
for arm one to be the best is that it's
better than arm two arm three on four
and five so that you can you could in
principle write it as a list of linear
inequalities
so that could be a way in which you do
it in general you list when is answer
six the right one
if this bunch of linear inequalities
happens
right so linear is maybe not super
powerful but you can
maybe you can tessellate in any
complicated boundary system
with a bunch of linear well i don't know
i'm just
imagining it does it need to be linear
for it to be a convex problem
this lower bound has some convexity to
it but it's also
inherently destroying some of the
convexity that
might be there so this is one of the
struggles even if you're solving
such a lower bound problem on a specific
instance
that some non-convexity will pop up and
you have to maybe be
smart i don't think the linearity is
is super important so if i give you
these prototypes
and i ask you to which one are you the
closest
depending on the distance that might
generate some cell structure with
nonlinear
boundaries the linear case is very nice
if it's like a
sort of a voronoi diagram but if the
distance is not
i guess you can maybe figure out maybe
bregman divergences would still have
linear boundaries but if it's something
else
i think you might get some sort of soap
does it cheat some partition of of
the banded space where each cell
corresponds to the cluster of bandits on
which some answer is
yeah what you should be saying but
yeah so we're currently quite far from
even thinking about this question we
have just barely started because even in
specific problems where
sort of the answer map is completely
fixed we're already struggling to solve
this lower bound problem
and it looks like we have to come up
with new tricks
every time so that tells you we we don't
have the
the full catalog yet of stuff to make
this compiler
because if every time you look at a
problem you find a new trick then
but you don't have all the tricks yet no
exactly
to spin this a little bit further it you
talk about
clinical trials and so on and for sure
that's important
but it seems that the framework is
applicable
to so much more than your kind of this
standard setting i'm thinking of
any agent being deployed anywhere as
something like this for example yeah
let's go back to
your classic reinforcement learning
problem you have a robot
you deploy it in a house and the first
thing
it could do is simply to go and explore
right such that it can then after that
do
a certain task or any task as good as
possible
and this connects with this do you know
this notion of things like universal
value functions
or like things like where
an agent is deployed in a world and all
it does
is it learns to get from one state to
the other state
and it chooses those states by itself so
it always selects two states and then it
says
how can i get from here to there and
then it learns this
so that it's once the time comes it's
maximally prepared to do any task
is there an inherent connection do you
think bandit
framing it as a bandit problem is more
principled or is it different
or no i think again these bandit
problems they are just to help you
think about this type of problems in the
most simple setting that you can imagine
but in practice i think you're often
your actions
influence the state so i think
one one thing that i've recently people
looking at
is what's called reward free exploration
so you're placed in an mdp which is the
typical arena for reinforcement learning
so you can take actions and you will
change the state
but the reward is not there so you just
see i was here i did this action i went
there
and then from there i did another action
i went there
and maybe one once in a while you come
back to a state where you've been before
and so your goal is to map out the map
in a sense and then at the very end
in such a way so this is then the reward
free exploration goal
learn this map in such a way that if i
then give you a reward function
you can actually give execute
a near optimal policy as a result of
your map making
yeah and no matter what reward function
i then lay on top
you should be able to now have such a
good map
that you can get to the high rewards in
in that way of measuring
so that's in some sense a pure
exploration problem
because you're you're doing this map
making without any reward
just trying to get your uncertainty
about the mdp
down in a smart uniform way right it's
you have to get you have to go
everywhere to get a gap map if there are
regions that you you don't even see
then if they have high rewards you don't
know
how to get there or i'm sensing a deep
connection here
uh team to the kenneth stanley novelty
search so we're definitely gonna have to
mention this when we have that
conversation abandoning objectives and
just searching
is there is there any consideration of
causality
in the field for example i can if i have
a patient
maybe i can give them by treatment
now but i could also have instructed
them three months earlier i could have
instructed them to just quit smoking
or two years earlier i could have
recommended them a better diet and so on
and these things
causally influence each other and i now
have to figure
out what is best to do when the things
have some some kind of causal structure
which node in the causal structure
am i intervening on things like this is
there any
consideration or is this a completely
different field
causality and exploration touch in
multiple
places so one one one way to look at
causality it's a
you can use it as a restriction on
sort of a joint distribution of random
variables
but it also tells you how they behave if
you take certain actions
but in in some sense without the causal
model
every action could do whatever and with
the causal model in place that restricts
quite a lot
what your actions would do so if you
have a causal model
underlying some bandit arms so those
would be your random variables
plus a causal model behind and that's
prior knowledge that would allow you to
with fewer samples recommend a good one
for example so there are papers that
talk about that
another thing you could try is to say i
don't know about
causal models but i'm willing to
discover them if they are present
but then i think the causality
literature is trying to figure out this
question
can you even learn the causal model from
doing interventions or experiments it's
maybe the same thing
and i think the answer is often no and
sometimes yes
but in some sense trying to figure out
the correct model
from observations that you actively and
or interactively place
[Music]
is what both of these are after
yeah there's a causal excuse me a causal
model
behind the arms if you will does that
fall somewhere in between
the normal multi-arm bandit and an
adversarial
multi-armed bandit like is the
adversarial multi-armed
bandit just a causal one or is it even
more generalized than a causal model
i think the adversarial one is really in
a category on its own
so in the stochastic bandit model even
if you have uh
prior knowledge about the structure or a
causal structure or it could be like
families or you know joint distributions
all these things are in a stochastic
setting
where if you figured out all the
parameters
you know everything so in some sense
there is
the thing to learn exists it is the full
parametrization
of the true model and it is within scope
to actually figure that out
so sometimes the parameter dimension is
large but typically if you keep on doing
the right experiments at some point
you're zooming in on that parameter more
and more
whereas in an adversarial setting there
is some opponent
that can put the rewards or control the
samples
and at that point all the structure
evaporates
right even samples from the same arm
don't have to look like each other there
could be patterns that in time
just appear and go away and
you typically see the learning rates
worsen
if you look at regret upper bounds you
go from the logarithmic to the square
root regime
the algorithms become much more
pessimistic
and the amount of exploration you need
even for reward maximization is just
higher because you have to catch the
opponent
changing the patterns in some sense it's
funny but i always
so exploration is in that sense you use
it as a threat
so i'm going to look i'm going to sample
but in principle i might look everywhere
all right so don't try to hide a reward
that i'm not seeing because i
i'm going to look uh
and by now and then by by having support
in your exploration
on all the arms you can make sure that
the
the probability that the adversary packs
a lot of reward in one place and you
miss it
is small could we touch on
optimization because this is something
that should be familiar to
most of the deep learning folks that
watch this podcast so we're in the
regime of convex optimization
and you mentioned in one of your talks
actually because clearly what we want to
do is minimize the regret
and the regret is the difference between
our approach
the best possible sequence of of actions
and one of the things that we need to do
with stochastic gradient descent is add
regularization
and you mentioned a couple of examples
of this so there's one which is the
ftrl style which is the follow the
regularized
leader which is penalizing eccentricity
and then there's another one which is
mirror descent
which is uh it's kind of similar to what
we
do in kernel methods right it's
transforming it into some
into some hilbert space and then doing
some update and then transforming it
back again as i understand
doing this mirror descent gives you a
better convergent
behavior i think it's instead of being a
square root of n over k it's a
square root of log n over k but yeah
could you give us some insight into some
of the optimization approaches
yeah so how to place optimization and
connected to our
conversation we've had so far so one of
the things you can say
is a multi-arm bandit
is in some sense a very simple
optimization problem
where i need to find the best out of a
finite set of arms
but you could extend this and say let's
imagine that there is an
infinite parameter space of arms
with some function that i don't know
which maybe controls the let's say there
is maybe some noise so it controls the
mean
and i'm trying to go to the minimum of
that
by carefully outputting these iterates
and asking for samples at the iterates
so this is one perspective it's called
bandit optimization where
yeah you're trying to see how many
iterates do i need to get close to a
certain point
it's typically done without gradients so
if you add
but in optimization where people are
designing these losses them
themselves right it's just some
misclassification error on an example or
something that you randomly draw from
your
from your training set then the loss
function so you can compute gradients
so then it's like first order gradient
based optimization
and then i guess the other connection is
you could also say
this is in some sense more related to
the full information
case so let's see is that my
misunderstanding so
mostly we use these convex optimization
approaches like stochastic
gradient to send in the full information
regime
it's true you use them in the full
information regime and on the other hand
you're typically
only using a gradient as your conduit
you're not taking the full sample or the
example on which
right in stochastic rating descent you
take
one example from your training set you
compute the
the gradient of the loss function of
your current parameters
on that example and then you update your
parameters
with a gradient step so you could have
used more information about your
example but instead you chose to only
look at the gradient
so that is in some sense a self-imposed
restriction
i mean you yeah you could think about
hessians and then very quickly you don't
want to because the demand that
is just interactively big
but you just to say you could do other
things with your data
one thing that i like to think about but
it's maybe somewhat removed from our
current conversation
is the online convex optimization
setting
so there you're not thinking about
optimizing a fixed function
or a stochastic function where you draw
examples from some distribution or
training set
but you're thinking about an adversary
picking those functions
for you and then it turns out that these
algorithms
for optimizing some of
adversarially chosen convex functions
they are super strongly related
to algorithms for full information and
banded learning
the idea behind is very similar like you
mentioned these
frameworks for obtaining algorithms like
mirror descent
ftrl there is also the sort of
exponential weights family
which sometimes
is a special case of mirror descent and
also vice versa it's quite intriguing
but anyway so making algorithms for that
gives you inspiration on making
algorithms for full information and
banded problems and vice versa
let me just say one of the things that i
find extremely
intriguing about designing such
algorithms
is that you want to make a guarantee
about the performance of these
algorithms to say
not just it works on this data set but
to say i promise that it will work
so and so well on your data set that i
haven't even seen yet
so you like to give such guarantees but
to make such guarantees you typically
have to be
quite pessimistic about what's going to
happen
your data is typically adversarial and
you make some bounce here and there and
so these guarantees come out
often pessimistic if you run your
algorithm in practice it will actually
perform better so you might say that's
fine i will just run it in practice and
it will
perform better and i'm happy with that
but you might be a bit greedier and say
i want to guarantee that if your problem
is of a specific kind
maybe somewhat non-adversarial or
simpler
then my algorithm will actually
guaranteed perform better
than its case guarantee so i think you
mentioned in the
introduction this adverse accelerated
learning
so that's what this is about so you want
to make a claim that says my performance
is such and such
so that if you look at the ingredients
of that claim you can see that oh
if my data are of a certain easy type
this closeness to optimality
goes down much quicker than if i'm in a
worst case example
so that reminds me of a question i want
to ask you because
you've just been talking about if the
more pessimistic you have to be
the looser the bounds get eventually
would just get the markov inequality or
something like that that's not so useful
maybe but another dimension that you
mentioned i think this is in a video
i saw a presentation that you made is it
why do we care about
asymptotic optimality to start with
because
we're not doing things infinitely we're
doing things with finite samples and we
care about getting the most value out of
those and one point
you made is that okay at least sometimes
the algorithms we develop when we
consider
asymptotic optimality uh
turn out to be good ones or maybe even
the best ones that we've discovered
i'm sure a lot of it has to do with just
analytic simplicity
it's easier to consider asymptotic cases
i wonder if you can talk more about
the first point there which is that
sometimes they turn out to be the good
algorithms and sometimes they don't i'm
just really curious about how that plays
out
in practice all right yeah so this is
maybe this is back
to the pure exploration bandit setting
so as i said before
i i think there was this renaissance so
this relates to that so what happened in
the renaissance
previously there were worst case
guarantees
and algorithms that gave them
right and you always wonder is such a
worst case guarantee any good
okay or is there still room to improve
the algorithm and gets
just a uniformly better guarantee
so that's why you are thinking about
lower bounds because if you match
your upper bounds with a lower bound
there is no way to make it
better in all cases and there was a
there so there is a for lower it's often
very difficult to be extremely precise
so with lower bounds and upper bounds
you typically make these statements that
i have like a big o
let's say up to a constant vector that
i'm not going to specify and who knows
how big it is but
you can't do better than this and i can
do at least this good
sure now in the renaissance it turns out
that it is possible to match the
lower bound which itself is not
asymptote
which itself is not up to an unspecified
constant the lower bound turns out to be
precise
and you can asymptotically match it so
this means that there are no big o's
right in the limit of large samples
you're doing exactly what the lower
bound says
up to some overhead that is sort of
vanishing compared to the main term
so that is very good news you it says
you can get
extremely close to optimality
on large samples so this is what this
asymptotic optimality the excitement
that it gave
like we can have the constant vector
equal to one on top of the lower bound
in our algorithms we can
really squeeze everything out but
so this argument was asymptotic
and of course that's it still makes you
wonder okay but at what sample sizes do
these asymptotics start kicking in
and the hope would be that's all fine
and they always kick in early
so then the theory guys have some work
to figure that out
but in practice i can just use these
algorithms because they work great
so that's the best case scenario turns
out this a bit
is a bit mixed so depending on the
problem
in which you in which you're working as
i said these lower bounds are the
template
they specialize to the problem in
different cases
so for best arm i think the lower bounds
the asymptotic algorithms
so based on these lower bounds actually
the asymptotics kick in quite early
so for practical sample sizes these
algorithms are are just
the the best we have for other problems
like the game tree search problems it's
a bit different
and i think the one of the interesting
and also
not so well understood things is that
the lower bounds for game trees tell you
that
some of the states in your game tree you
don't have to evaluate them at all
so this is a pruning related issue
right if you do for example alpha beta
search you're also
not going to look at some subtrees this
is different because it's like
stochastic
evaluation so you're you have to revisit
things it's not you can really prune
something but these lower bounds say
some states don't need
any samples but i can still give the
correct answer even if i haven't seen
any samples from this
arm that says is something that is
dangerous because if you follow a
strategy
that does not sample in one spot
and your estimates are not right
then it might be that you're never going
to correct your estimates because to
correct them you would have to see
samples from
really that place so to get that
there is a self-confusing possibility in
these algorithms
which you fix by doing sort of a
baseline sampling everywhere
at the low frequency so that it doesn't
kill your guarantees
but that still your estimates eventually
converge
so in the asymptotic optimality you
don't see this it's just
a thing that eventually disappears but
in practice it i think it matters a lot
how you actually
do this and so the asymptotics don't
give any guidance
as to how to do it they just say make
sure that in the limit it disappears
but we haven't figured out quite how to
do this there are now
an another point touching on your
question is that these asymptotic
optimality results are just some
intermediate stage
right nobody is happy and thinks that's
the place to stop
it's just if they give good algorithms
then in practice we can go
and in theory we have to work that out
if they don't give good algorithms it
means we have to understand it at an
even finer scale and
and maybe actually sit down do the work
and get these finite time results
also figured out that is typically much
harder
because then all these other details
that you could sweep under the rock with
asymptotics
actually start mattering so we're seeing
the first
sort of non-asymptotic bounds both for
regret minimization with instance
optimal results
and also pure exploration they are
happening
but they are not at the stage where
where we believe that the
sort of the lower order terms that are
being added to make things
non-asymptotic that those are actually
correct
we believe there are gross overestimates
with all sorts of artifacts of the
analysis etc
so we're not at this and
maybe they are guiding their algorithm
so we don't have this interaction
figured out that we i think there is
work needed to press those down and make
the algorithm adjust so that you can do
that
amazing i was wondering where in all of
this
do let's say something like features
come in because we've now we've seen
okay you have
x treatments and treatments are simply
labeled one through ten you wanna find
the best one and so on but now
let's let's reverse and let's say i have
these ten
treatments and i have a pool of a
thousand patients
and all of these patients they have
different ages and
weights and what not in previous
diseases and whatnot
and now not only do i have to select the
right
treatment but i also have to say which
patient do i want to try it on
in such a way that at the end i know
the most things about most treatments on
most patients
where how does that come in and does
deep learning
play a potential role in that once you
deal with features
all right so i think the the standard
way to add features to a bandit problem
is called the contextual bandit and
the model there is that in as you say a
patient comes in their
age their shoe size their coordinates
and the goal is not to find the best
treatment
but the goal is to learn a function that
takes such a feature factor
and says for you the best treatment is
this drug
yeah right so it could still be a finite
number of drugs
but now instead of learning one out of
five
you're learning among all functions from
the feature space to a five element
let's say set of drugs okay so the
object you're trying to learn
just became a lot more complicated
because there might be lots of functions
mapping
between those two so you typically need
if you wanna so the general problem if
you have no structure whatsoever
in the class of functions you are
considering is hopeless
because you you could have if the
features are
random with like a no limits on the
support
you're never going to see the same
patient twice and if the
best treatment for everybody is
completely arbitrary there is no
learning from the patients
who treat it so then people look at
function classes
like what sort of mappings from the
features to the best drug am i going to
try to learn from and so
because you have two questions you have
the question like how does it affect the
sample size
so i'm learning something more precise
so i expect to do better
if i learned it but i also expect to
need much more samples to learn it
so you'd like to know for example
suppose i do only linear maps
or maybe softmax if you want from
features to drugs
how many samples do i expect to learn
such a map
is that sort of practical or not maybe
it is a function of the feature vector
size or something
and the other thing is how am i going to
learn such a function in the first place
what often happens is that this is done
through a reduction so you're reduced to
supervised learning
where you say i'm going to create a data
set with all the observations that i
made in the past and i will feed that to
a supervised learning system
to output me a classifier that gives me
the mapping that i want
so this is where all your supervised
learning
tools could do that job yeah yeah so
i think this is a very hot and current
topic to do this
i think there are computational barriers
as well so it's
it's not all rosy people are often going
there are several papers that work in
sort of an oracle model where they say
minimizing the loss over the
function class i assume that's tractable
we know it's not but let's assume it and
then see if we can get the statistical
problem under control
of how to do the sampling aspect so
here's a maybe a crazier idea
if i don't know how much time you spend
in the deep learning world
but there is a class of models called
transformers
then they have this attention mechanism
and the attention mechanism
basically maps a set to another set
and it does so by computing features on
each pair
of these sets which means that you have
a quadratic blow up
in memory and in compute time
and a lot of people have tried to make
that mapping
sparse doing the things is there any use
to formulate this as a bandit problem
as a as an as a let's say maybe even a
pure exploration problem where you say
here are incoming features
of my sample in my neural network layer
and
i have to select a subset of those to
propagate to the next layer
because i i simply can't compute all of
them
is this a viable banded problem or
is the work required to determine
which of the features i pass on is that
just the same
as actually computing them you see where
i'm getting it
yeah can i put a band-aid problem within
my neural network to make it sparse or
is that does that defeat the purpose
because the bandit itself
would compute all of these things anyway
so i i'm not sure
i'm not that i'm not familiar with the
transformers specifically
but i i have worked on some problem that
has at least
well pretty related when you work with
the learning from
from features a thing that is often
coming up is that you would like to have
sort of a covariance matrix
of those features yes sometimes you need
this sort of to normalize
things or whiten things or to like also
in but also in adversarial learning
these matrices come up
and so once the dimension gets a million
or depends on your budget let's say over
a thousand ten thousand
it's really annoying or impossible to
store that matrix
and so you can ask like how much do i
lose
if i approximate that matrix and throw
away some of the entries
and a thing that you can do is you can
say let's try to maintain
a low rank factorization of it and throw
away the rest
and it turns out that in terms of
optimization performance you're going to
lose something
because you're not keeping everything
but it is a manageable amount
in the sense that i guess the rates are
known for these type of approaches if
you maintain this
this matrix you would be in a
logarithmic regret
regime if you don't maintain it and do
maybe gradient descent it would be a
square root
and if you do a matrix sketching
technique
that sort of adaptively tries to put
some things in the matrix and
kick some other things out and there are
some svds on the way etc
but the the upshot is that you get
logarithmic regime
on the important dimensions in your
problem
which is also the ones that you are
approximately keeping in the matrix
and then there is a square root t regret
on everything that you dropped
but hopefully the magnitude of the
dropped things
yeah which is multiplying that square
root is small enough that you were
okay dropping it and so there are
interesting trade-offs there
making completely impractical algorithms
rather practical so maybe something like
that could also
work for the transformer case yeah
and it's important to realize already
when you're talking about a pairwise
matrix it's already a reduction of the
problem space
because now we're not considering
three-way four-way in-way kind of
functional interactions between things
like this is a problem that
props up even an old-school kind of i've
got my
correlation matrix and i reduce it to
some eigenvectors
and now i've lost information but not
only that but you've lost things beyond
pairwise
relationships so it's always i guess
maybe amuse me or something surprise me
and how much we have to reduce the
complexity of the real world
just to get it down to things that we
can mathematically address
indeed you you said in one of your other
presentations uh
welter as well that there's also a
moderate confidence regime
which is because we spoke about the
fixed confidence regime where it's
dependent on the problem parameters
other than the is it that the lowercase
delta that is in our problem
that's right in this asymptotic
optimality
you're saying let's look at what happens
if i make my confidence parameter
go to zero which means that you are
you're allowing
fewer and fewer mistakes because that's
what the confidence is your mistake
budget the probability that you make a
wrong
output so if you make that super tiny
what how does the sample complexity go
up
that's the asymptotic regime and so
all the things that what you often see
is you have sort of a
in your sample complexity a contribution
that scales with that
confidence and other stuff that doesn't
and the asymptotic says okay only the
factor in front of the term that scales
with the confidence
is important because the rest vanishes
eventually
so the moderate confidence research line
is the counter
revolution to that which says come on
in practice delta is five percent one
percent
maybe space grade a million but that's
it
and if at those deltas those
second order terms are actually the
dominating ones
then your asymptotically optimal picture
is not even telling us what's really
going on
and so then the question becomes like
those other terms
what do they actually depend on so how
do they scale maybe with the number of
arms
or maybe with some other structural
parameters that i have in my prior
knowledge things like that
and and can they be dominant so there
are some papers that have
okay let's say so the holy grail would
be
some expression that takes that is not
asymptotic takes all these effects into
account
and ideally has a lower bound that says
you need all these things as well
and but we're not there
but we do have cases where there are
examples where
the lower order terms are the dominant
ones so the terms that don't depend on
the confidence
determine the sample complexity and they
have interesting scalings with the
number of arms
and these other problem parameters so
that is really a criticism to the
asymptotic optimality saying
you're looking at a very special tail
end
of a big elephant that has much more to
it
we're not done
so i take this as a very as a sort of
interesting in the sense that that means
that the algorithms that we currently
have
are probably not going to survive and be
in the canon
and there is a new class of algorithms
if we just
push a little bit it's just a little bit
behind the horizon
that would be getting those those terms
and ideally both of them
a question though so how much would that
refinement let's say that so today we
have some algorithms and and
in one case we do linear allocation and
another it's logarithmic and you made
this comment earlier that
there's this very steep kind of energy
barrier there if you will where you care
about one thing
it drives you over to a particular class
of algorithm
so somebody comes along and they they
present us with god's theta bound or
something that has
all the little terms in there i'm
wondering like how much that's going to
change
like practical implementation of those
algorithms
because again i'm coming back to this
seems like it could be extremely useful
for policy making we had to just talk
about algo shambles in the uk where they
were trying to do college admissions and
they had an algorithm that would do
things like
no top-tier students ever came from this
school then we're going to allocate
zero budget to them and yannick brought
up maybe some kind of laplacian
smoothing would have helped out there
and that's very that's a multi-armed
bandit
you know problem so i'm curious how much
you think these refinements
those bounds would qualitatively change
the algorithms that are optimal yeah so
i think unfortunately the algorithms are
very different so the the examples in
which
the non confidence terms are dominant
have different lower bounds with that
term being the dominant one and then the
algorithms that match those
look very different again so that says
that
if you want to get both of these we have
to interpolate
somehow in a smart way another way of
looking at it is saying
those asymptotically optimal algorithms
are not maybe safe for practice
a theoretical reason for why they aren't
safe
is that they're getting this other thing
wrong
that's too bad yeah
in terms of what you want to do in
practice i mean if you are in an example
where you can simulate and try your
algorithm
on on representative problems that are
not exactly the one you have but you
believe they're close
you can just best run your algorithm and
see
if you trust it so the sampling rule
might be
suboptimal for the
for the regime or not but as long as
your stopping rule is safe
maybe you take maybe a little bit too
many examples but you're still giving
the right answer
so you can be safe while at the same
time be a little bit heuristic
and i think at least for these best arm
type problems you will get the best
performance by doing that
so i think if i had to implement them in
practice for some
drug trials maybe i would still consider
doing them see i love that i love how
this is one thing i always found really
interesting about algorithms
is like he's saying you set up this
problem and and here's our objective
function
and then you figure out however you
figure it out what an optimal algorithm
is
and a lot of times they come up to be
these sort of very simple rules
like you you allocate logarithmically or
linearly
or whatever and they're quite robust to
changes to the objective functions and
problems like that
but it sounds like in some of these
scenarios he's talking about
the algorithm the optimal algorithms
are not that stable you go and you you
tweak your
asymptotic bound or something and now
suddenly it's telling you to do
square root allocation instead of linear
kind of funny you know it's a bit
unfortunate as you would hope that
for things like the algo shambles or
whatnot if we just did a little bit of
multi-arm bandit proper analysis we
could come up with an
algorithm that's objectively fair and
achieves our goal
of bettering society as a whole that
sort of thing
yeah but it's i think the fact is that
you have to make sure that
in the limit they somehow converge so
that they they can be arbitrarily bad in
the
short term but then in in the long term
as long as they converge that reminds me
of
like in optimization there are a lot of
these papers
that do all all kinds of stuff where
as long as at the end you converge it's
fine like
think yeah this algorithm reaches global
convergence
in deep learning and all you have to do
is like noise around
until you are in the region of the local
of the
like in the region around the optimum
where it's approximately convex
and then you converge but as long as you
noise around all like this this
algorithm design often the algorithms
are designed with this asymptotic
thing in mind and they pay the price of
being arbitrarily bad
in the short term or in the near term
and that's
it seems yeah it seems as you've said
about her this seems
a bit sad and it also is not
super clear what then you should do in
practice and
in as in bandits in optimization where i
know
a little bit of stuff we're not there
yet
to say look here is a good algorithm for
your problem
all we know is that what tends to work
well
in a thing and almost nobody cares about
the asymptotic properties of an
optimization algorithm
when you apply it no one cares we just
use
adam or sgd or whatever worked last time
and then people have their favorites i
don't know does that happen to you
in the bandit world where i know people
they they'll come like you just need to
use rms
prop it's better every time and
they'll just use that and it like
there's literally no just use thompson's
sampling
they're all they're cut they're
convinced does that happen in the banded
world in practice that people go no i
use this one it's always better
murphy sam but maybe they do it with
they tried it
so i think one of the sort of large
application cases is
advertisements on websites
where every round is a new user
maybe it's contextual maybe some the
country
browser history depending on who you are
some things about the user maybe you use
it maybe you don't
and you have to recommend one of a small
set of advertisements
in principle that if you keep on you
know pushing the same advertisement at
some point the attention of the
users will decline and and so
it's not an iid stochastic setting
or people are even better like your
competitor is making a counter
advertisement and now yours looks
ridiculous instead of
fun like you intended it anyway
so then you'd go oh okay maybe i should
use an adversarial banded algorithm
and then you see your revenue just drop
so it's safe but it also doesn't work
that well
yeah so you just go back to the
stochastic case where the assumptions
are violated
but not that much to actually be heard
and it's more aggressive so you run it
of course if you believe the if you
believe the sort of i don't know if hype
is right word but the exaggeration if
you will from the social dilemma
the social media companies are out there
scooping up all the multi-armed bandit
experts i've designed like highly
optimized
you know algorithms to poke them with
with certain ad whereas in practice i
don't know what i've seen is
most of the time it's something simple
we want to make this ux improvement so
we're going we're gonna run half
the users on the new one and half on the
old one for a week and uh see which one
does better
it's just like these simple rational
number divisions of things
is there is there any things that you
are excited about
that are in the near future of the pure
exploration field
of things where that could make a big
impact or just that
seem like lots of fun to you yes i i
think this
thinking about this pure exploration
compiler
i think if we get that it would be
massively useful
because the user can specify what is the
thing i want to learn
and what is the knowledge that i have
and now synthesize me an algorithm
right without having a researcher
working for you
or so any sort of steps towards that
i think are going to be fun
and useful at the same time and fun i
guess for me it means
you discover sort of new ways of
designing algorithms right these tricks
that i was talking about
every time you get such a trick i
i don't know you really feel like i
discovered something that nobody has
seen before it's super exciting
and then you're building this library
for this sort of grand goal
i think yeah someone mentioned the
murphy sampling in this regard
it's also one of these algorithms that
unfortunately it as far as we know it
only applies to one specific scenario
but it is a competitive for that one
yeah this algorithm is is fun it's
maybe i can explain it briefly
so you're in a situation where i call it
a tree of depth one and a half
so the situation is as follows you can
either you have a binary choice
so you can either have some fixed reward
or you can make choice two and in choice
two there is a multi-arm bandit
so there is a bunch of choices but those
are controlled by an opponent
okay so the opponent is going to give
you the reward from the bandit which is
the worst
so you can either have fixed reward
or go to this bandit in which you will
get the worst of the arms
so now you can have some time with this
bandit
before we actually play this game so you
can take samples
from these arms to figure out how bad is
the
worst arm among these right so you do
your learning for a while you figure it
out and then
you play the actual game do we go for
the fixed rewards or do we
get to the bandit so the question is how
to organize
this learning in this bandit
with this extra little binary tree right
above it
and so for this we developed the murphy
sampling algorithm
so if you're familiar with thompson
sampling it's a super nice idea
you have some priors on the quality of
your arms
you get samples and you update those
priors to become posteriors
and then there is the rule for taking
samples
which is you take a posterior sample and
you
look at the best arm on that sample and
that's the one
that you play and get a new sample from
yeah there's always samples on two
levels with thompson
the one in your fantasy and the one in
the bandit
so you sample a perimeter from your
posterior and go with the best arm
on that parameter to play and what
murphy sampling
does it's a nice variation it says
do a posterior sample and look at
the worst arm
if it is worse than that fixed
value that i can also have
then let's play that arm but if all the
arms are better than that fixed value
then i don't like this posterior sample
so i reject and get
and resample until i get a one
where there is an arm below this
threshold
so the way i look at it is this
algorithm it takes posterior samples
but it's conditioning on these bad
bandits where
the the worst arm is worse than the
constant value
and it only likes to think about those
and it turns out this is the right thing
to do even if you're in a good bandit
but that's weird because you're never
thinking about good bandits this
algorithm
and it's only considering bad bandits so
that's why
we call it murphy sampling but for some
funny mathematical coincidence or or not
but we don't know
only thinking about bad bandits still
give you exactly the right behavior
on the good bandits too which is
yeah it's it's one of these tricks so
there are
there should be a library of tricks that
look like bumps and sampling with
variations that include sort of
rejection sampling
maybe some interesting conditioning
events can you create one of those
libraries
it could be very useful i don't know yet
what should be in it
so i i have this one example then we try
i tried with a
master student from italy it was a right
guy
to extend it to actual depth too
so i said i called this depth one and a
half because it was a
choice between a constant and a bandit
so just the simple extensions where you
can have you have a binary choice
between two bandits
but in each of them you will get the
sample from the worst arm
so you want to go left or right and you
have some prior time in which you can
interact with both bandits
before you make your choice so we
thought hard about
making a thompson sampling based
algorithm for this
but in the end we couldn't figure it out
so we don't know if it's possible
but until now we weren't able to do it
so again yeah you need more tricks
smarter tricks
or it's impossible but that would
probably also be very hard to show
amazing doctor walter kulin
it's been an absolute pleasure and thank
you so much for coming on the show this
evening
thank you thanks for all your questions
i learned
more than i ever have and i've had three
lectures on
bandits like full semesters
goes to show you the socratic method or
dialogue is the best way to learn huh
right you were connecting all these
things to
lots of other topics in machine learning
which i think is is very nice i think
you're getting a good overview of what's
going on by making these uh
interviews yeah yannick video incoming
well thank you so much yeah for being
here this was lots of fun
thank you it was a pleasure to meet you
real pleasure that's a wrap
thanks a lot amazing i i really
appreciate it
and yeah we'd love to have you on again
soon so thank you so much
really was a pleasure thank you for
taking the time to talk to us
thanks for the opportunity pleasure cool
take care guys have a great weekend
good luck with the podcast thanks so
much cheers yeah
you'll see it soon bye-bye cheers guys
bye thanks
we've got a tiny bit of bonus postscript
content here
unfortunately we don't have a recording
for wowter but there are some
nice contributions from keith and
yannick so i've just left this in
i'm not sure if you're familiar with
kind of the theory of computation
sort of literature you always i know
you've heard about mp complete and
whatnot the funny thing is
np stands for non-deterministic turing
machine and so
this is like a turing machine that
anytime it needs to branch it can just
explore
both both avenues in parallel
simultaneously and then no matter how
much it branches whatever the sort of
results are can be coalesced back to
the final answer so that's obviously an
extremely powerful
machine and quantum doesn't even get to
that level it's a step below that where
it can evaluate some
finite number of very specifically
superimposed
sorts of states and we have to be clever
about how to use it
but i just find it's it's so hyped it's
like at the peak almost not i don't know
where it is in the gartner hype cycle
but
it's it's not going to solve all our
problems
damn wow yeah yeah we should like do
street talk quantum something
like it's something i hear companies
getting
funding for things that have nothing to
do with what the company does
but they like frame their work in a way
it's oh yeah we got some covet funding
it's like you do you're like you do
nothing no
quantum quantum bottled water yeah right
it's only a matter of framing to get
these government
money things blockchain coffee
we commented on that on our last video
or the one before the last was diverged
into the woes of
academia and you brought up this
repeatability
uh crisis yeah i found that politics and
money really corrupted the process and i
was really naive as a kid i thought it
was really the ivory tower and that
all that mattered was the truth and and
if you could demonstrate the truth
everyone else just had to spontaneously
accept it and accept the new truth and
move forward and it's not like that at
all it's just so much hype and politics
and
sort of religions and acolytes that
follow the religious leaders
and and vociferously attack anyone that
disagrees
remember to like comment and subscribe
and we'll see you back very soon